a suspicious package of the palace
controversy over awards show glam and a
rare appearance by the Queen we're
spilling the royalty hi everybody i'm
lauren zima and the tea is scary hot
today we're starting off with some
serious news British authorities are
investigating an envelope addressed to
Prince Harry and Megan Markel that
contained a white substance but you can
breathe a sigh of relief a source
confirmed to ET the substance was tested
and was not anthrax Plus even though the
envelope was sent to the palace it never
made it near Megan and Harry thanks to
systems in place to sort through
anything is sent to the Royals still a
threat is always alarming so here's what
we know about how our American princess
is being kept safe she's looked after at
events you can see Megan's team watching
over her at her appearance in Scotland
and we've learned the identity of this
woman by her side near the crowds
that's Megan's new official royal aid
she'll coordinate her schedule and take
care of any correspondence sent her way
unfortunately threats to the royal
family aren't anything new so we've got
the inside scoop on special survival
training Harry and Megan are expected to
go through and it sounds like the stuff
of movies they have a live range that
they called the killing house and I know
that Princess Diana and Charles they
went into the killing house and they
were shown that live hostage situation
and they even took part in that training
themselves as a hostage well that seems
terrifying but where is our brave future
princess now we haven't seen Megan since
that trip to Scotland
Harry was out alone photographed at a
training session for the English rugby
team and we do know the two had a
private date night at a showing of
Hamilton in London's West End
[Music]
yes relax with some three-part harmonies
you too you deserve it and Brits we're
trusting you to keep our Megan safe
luckily we know you've got the best
people bond James Bond
now let's talk something slightly less
petrifying controversial fashion duchess
Kate and Prince William stunned at
Britain's BAFTA Awards Sunday that's
their version of the Oscars but Kate's
Jenny Packham dress had some people
throwing shade the Duchess's way here's
why other attendees were black in
support of The Times up movement
Kate's gown is clearly green thankfully
we've discovered there was a reason for
this dress decision the royal family is
supposed to stay politically neutral all
the time they can't even vote so what
would you suggest
Prime Minister some kind of a statement
still I like to think that little black
ribbon was Kate giving us ladies a knot
of support after all what's more British
than girl power
[Music]
we're going to wrap things up with a
true delight for you guys a surprise
appearance by the clear 91 year old
Queen Elizabeth made her first ever
London Fashion Week appearance and it
was everything like the true baller that
she is
she sat front row next to none other
than Vogue editor and a winter oh my god
they talked the Queen laughed she made
an aspire this is unbelievable guys the
Queen presented the inaugural queen
elizabeth ii award for british design to
richard Quinn he's known for being an
avant-garde designer which is evident by
this woman walking by the Queen in a
tie-dye motorcycle helmet and what we
can only describe as polkadot socks
shoes can you imagine if that's what you
met the Queen wearing like your majesty
hi then again the designer himself was
in Becky's plaid and a baseball cap hey
guys it's 2018 the palace is going
modern by the way this is the award
itself and it is very beautiful but does
it remind anyone else of anything
[Music]
that's all for this week royal obsessors
thankfully over at easy online comm
we've got more to tickle your fancy
including photos of Prince William
looking like a movie star on a
motorcycle he was celebrating Britain's
vehicle manufacturing and simultaneously
bringing out his sexy side plus from
Black Tie to hard hat Will and Kate got
their hands dirty at the site of a new
bridge and you won't believe what she
wore underneath her neon vest
that's all Aditi online.com until next
time i'm lauren zima cheerio
[Music]